I mean it'll be a while before anybody's
excited about anybody fighting John
Jones because it's like what do you got
you know you got a dude who's just
there's certain guys like remember when
Anderson was in his prime and like look
what are you gonna who he gonna throw at
him there was nobody there to Wiedeman
came along everybody that they threw it
I mean you're like what's Anderson gonna
do to this dude
when's Aniston got a knockout you should
know commie when is he gonna connect on
this guy mitt I think we're in that
situation now with John you know we got
the Thiago Santos fight that's coming up
should be interesting yeah but it's just
the interesting is that Santos is a
murderous striker what is he gonna be
able to connect that's the that's what
makes it interesting
I think Jones has some of the best
defense the best wrestling grappling
yeah and striking just doesn't get hit
yeah
distance side kick to your fucking
kneecap is no longer there and then when
you fucking thinking about that side
kick boom left elbow to the eye orbital
yeah it's a tough puzzle he's like and
he's he doesn't he's not light on his
feet he's just right there in front of
you like an unmovable force you know
he's just gonna stand right there in
front of you he's not gonna go back or
nothing it's just if he catches you
catching a break you try to take a
breath of air whap wow wow wow pouring
it on you so it's kicking your legs
front kicking you in the body over and
over and sees you slowing down he's a
predator man I wish like they can make a
science experiment make Mighty Mouse 205
that fight happened or shrink John Jones
I make that fight happen yeah no shit
right no shit that would be crazy
see the thing is no 205 ur can move like
mighty mouse moves you would have to see
how can Mighty Mouse move at 205 yeah
cuz the thing is I don't gravity yeah
there's no gravity fuckin with him yeah
when he's 125 he's fuckin cut and angles
and he's whoo where is it yeah you know
he's on your legs he could do everything
but it's technique so it's also that's
right soon when I seem doing the things
like kicks like a fucking tie dude
shoots a double leg like a fucking good
wrestling dude it's not like just an
athletic guy that's explosive everything
is done just right you know same thing
with John you know it's got great
technique everywhere yeah I mean Matt
Hume has produced some great fighters
but
then there's Mighty Mouse like he's
produced some great talent but then
there's Mighty Mouse he's like stands
way out and you gotta wonder is it
Mighty Mouse is it Matt Hume put more
emphasis on him is it a combination I
think skew usually when you get a guy
that's that good you get a gym that
starts producing multiple champions like
that